jojo was geht hier zwei marx und
herzlich willkommen zur nächsten folge
mein kraftniveau hallo okay so sollten
wir wir haben nicht irgendwo sowieso
übersteuert das gradmesser wir haben uns
was vorgenommen
für diese folge ich werde die melonen
anbauen die ich in großer zahl geklaut
habe und davor erstmal kommt hier meine
lieben freunde der emrich rein und wir
erholen uns unseren platz zurück ich
muss jetzt halt vorsichtig sein und
lieber ein bisschen zu viel blut rein
machen weil das definition sketche
braucht ihr erstmal ein plateau pumps zu
machen und ich kann so also nicht
überwachen
nochmal zur erinnerung destination
zetsche zeigt an wie viel blut energie
in dem altar drin ist ich brauch 5000
weiß aber nicht genau wie viel grad drin
ist und wenn ich mich einmal komplett
opfere also zehn herzen
dann kommt glaube ich 2000 lebenspunkte
rein deshalb muss ich jetzt einfach so
ein bisschen draußen rumlaufen und
beobachten dass das nicht leer wird
bevor der nächste blatt auch hier wieder
entsteht mit latten menschen kann man
sich im visier ist um damit machen oder
hast du damit pvp vorjahr kann sich mit
blood magic die stärkste rüstung aus dem
ganzen markt machen also liebe die
wirkweise von der lebensenergie genährt
und wenn du dann irgendwie das schlau
anstellt und dir
ok der platz ist wieder da wenn du das
schlau anstellt und die irgendwie eine
farm aus die unendliche lebensenergie
macht dann kannst du ganz einfach ja
quasi unsterblich werden es sei denn du
kassierst viel zu viel schaden so ist
das also beziehungsweise ich sag jetzt
ganz einfach so einfach ist es natürlich
auch nicht aber ist es zeit glaube ich
so die einzige möglichkeit dass man
unsterblich wird in dem in den markt
weil es gibt ja keine andere rüstung die
dich irgendwie nicht unbesiegbar macht
falls es zu sehr bestimmt schon
irgendwelchen anderen städten so wie ich
dich kenne petric
leute wir haben unsere nation die wie
nations titel wieder
und ach komm ich melde mich an bist du
schon wieder nacht
es ist doch ein witz früher habe ich
mich beschwert dass niemals nach 28 wird
und jetzt ist irgendwie nur noch nachts
so geht also bei mir weiß garnicht
rumänen haben wir allgemein das gefühl
so bei mir mehr weiß ich nicht was
schlimmes sei froh drum & partner sind
auf dem server und muss nun die kredite
die nicht du kannst du für mich töten
hätte ich nicht schreiben können aber
gut dass jetzt gerade geschrieben
die maler die würde ich klatschen
stammplatz mehr leute die haben ja alle
die sind auch in den titeln strate hat
eine dimension die unser portal geht
auch in die pension
leute ich geh jetzt einfach für die hand
experience pack noch ein bisschen was
regen wobei ich baue ist hier erst mal
mein dach fertig aber es ist halt auch
gefährlich du willst du bewegst dich
immer so ein bisschen am limit zum
sterben halt wenn du die ganze zeit dein
blut opfern muss lasst uns aber es muss
halt so sicher bist da wo das was er
kann ja eigentlich nichts passieren so
stimmig schalke folgen sprach seinem
typisch ich überlege ich habe gar nicht
damit gerechnet dass ich so schnell
wieder mein zeug redet und da ist schon
wieder egal ich hab letzte folge was in
echtzeit ungefähr zehn minuten her ist
solche die die beiden natur ausgekippt
und jetzt sind hier einfach wieder drei
an dieser stelle oder die sind nicht
schlimm aber nervig altweil machen die
diese dummen sounds viel energie bin
krank ich für einen scheißdreck
für euch gern im rugby nein was die
viecher saugen deine energie also so
ganz ungefährlich sind jedoch nicht muss
man schon sagen so ein bisschen bauen
mir wieder
und hier die die schöne farben bisschen
voranbringen die kraniche essens farm
kran also irgendwie muss man mal was
richtiges anpflanzen aber das problem
ist ich glaube so eine farm bringt gar
nichts auf dem server weil es wächst ja
gar nicht wenn er wenn der offline ist
ich meinte ich weiß nicht ich bin dafür
jagen schiessen
ja gut finden aber jack ist immer so
keine ahnung wenn beim anpflanzen
dambeck wenn das wachsen würde dann dann
wächst das halt aber unsere meisten so
was kann ich denn jetzt überhaupt machen
noch jemand mein dach bauen ja aber
irgendwie ist es gerade so komisch ich
habe irgendwie alles geschafft kommen ja
wollte mir auf jeden fall innerhalb
einer der nächsten folgen die grasheimer
jährige us tränen geben genau dann kann
ich fliegen würde
darauf freue ich mich schon gras
irgendwie das fliegen ist einfach man
einfach einfach weiß zu chili ist das
wird ja jeder noch so brenzligen
situation einfach zweimal in die luft
klickt man bist du ganz woanders ist
wirklich ein traum mal das ist falsch
jedoch fand natürlich außerhalb über
diesen fall schon funktioniert ja nicht
meine schöne da es gibt eine falsche
richtung reduktion also dass keine
falschen kriegs aber die funktioniert ja
nicht auf die kurse es ist ein lied
findet die umrüstung in kraft die nz
bonus von jump ost haben krass
automatisch auf fall der manager
na gut aber es hilft wahrscheinlich ganz
auf oder also halt verloren haben die
und kämpfen so paarmann unser 400 große
idee ja ich hoffe irgendwie dass ich
keine ahnung dadurch dass sie jetzt hier
so zeug machen
irgendwann später irgendwie schneller an
dieser vier zu kommen weiß ja ja ja am
anfang nicht so aufwendig fahren muss
das lasse lieber die ich machen halt
risiko was können wir noch einen dungeon
vornehmen dann ja das kannst du auch
machen aber dann gefertigt märkten will
ich das nicht eigentlich machen stimmt
also wenn ich in pension gehen kann man
da auch da kann man auch im ernstfall
blood stone als das glaube ich sogar
welche traditionen und das eine blut die
menschen halt und ja da kannst du halt
ärzte platz du kannst auch in assen
damit schwer die sie machen
das kommt jetzt auch recht auf vor
eigentlich wenn du dich rein krebs und
das plateau kannst du auch seine rüstung
machen
mit platz neun und ich hatte meine ich
die top referee da keine ahnung ich weiß
jetzt auf den set bei uns hat aber halt
gerne alle rüstung halt gehalt schützen
dich genauso gleich stark ja klar der
beste set bundes ist wahrscheinlich der
den du hast wobei du hast heraus geboren
dass sie gar nicht gegenspieler geht
denn er geht nicht gibt's wieder da
warst du eigentlich rückblicken
überfluss kann dafür da immer gemacht
hast sag mal so zwei gegen eins japan
yvonne nicht aber trotzdem
trotz unter stärkere ja gut an weiß halt
trotzdem schon seit der zaubert alonso
ja klar
stimmt da oben können wir auch mal
kümmern was auch schon mit den ganzen
büchern gemacht ich dir gegeben
ich hab ja nicht alle benutzt aber ich
habe richtig viele habt ihr benutzung ab
drauf wie heißt es habt ihr
mitteleinsatz aubert hat glaube ich nur
schade dass um protection bekommen das
hättest du das epi sowie warum er
serviert nun einfach einen richtigen
alter machen können
ich meine dass man auf level 30
verzaubern kann erwärmen auch bei nicht
genug bücher okay gut und fertig wird
man das autohaus rinsdorf ausgerufen ich
habe das ganze dorf leer gemacht dass
bücher angeht
dabei ist viel viel besser vertritt auf
level 30 zu verzaubern
als nicht hast du bist halt ein 73 mal
damit reißt eine ganze level welches
einmal zaubert auf you're low when do
kombiniert kritischer ist also immer
safe deine sachen jedoch an bis gut aber
dann trotzdem bahnhofs teil wird wer ist
da wahrscheinlich am schlafen die die
sachen selbst zu vertreten so bei saphir
ist halt auch krasse thomas jetzt in
hellersen heftige schwert so als selten
ist machst dann level 30
ich hab das singleplayer probiert ich
hab da beim zehnten mal erstens offene
stadt damals einfach bauen auf dieses
bombay auf irgendwas immer drei manchen
ländern seite bekommen so 55 und dann
denkst du scheiße meinem bett fällt es
schwer das beim dimension gedroppt ist
jetzt mit so einer taktik shooter fest
weil so ein dimensionen schwerte habe ja
schon recht das wäre schon echt stressig
so ich hoffe mal dass kommen wir bis zur
nächsten folge das zeigt jetzt bin ich
auf jeden fall nochmal mich ein bisschen
um die essensversorgung der stadt
kümmern ist ja auch definitiv eine
aufgabe die man so als als bürgermeister
wahrnehmen sollte oder eine chance und
ich wollte noch mal genau
auch bürgermeister mäßig wollte ich am
portal vorne nochmal ein bisschen so ein
schwarz so ein schwarzes brett quasi
aufstellen oder nimmer nachrichten dran
kommen so das stimmt es doch vom
bürgermeister und sowas kommt schicken
also was ich will ja nur ein appell dass
wir andere städte angreifen können
es ist ja hoffentlich nicht zu viel
verlangt oder sonst kannst du auch gerne
ausreißen das ist natürlich wieder nacht
leute daraus werde ich jetzt erst mal
mehr und sie zu machen und die alle hier
unten anbauen
also ich laufe jetzt natürlich wieder
ohne essen ihr kennt mich
wir haben heute dienstag genau das
passiert steht
ich stelle gleich stark um dich rum
stark geschrumpft ich ein ja ja es ist
wieder soweit ist ist wieder soweit
leute mich an ich bin tot sagte wasser
gekämpft cyclops nederland halt überall
mops weil es nachts war ich wollte
gerade einfach nur die melonen anbauen
gehen und dann wurde ich in so ein loch
eingeschlagen als dann waren also das
ist und jetzt ist die nacht vorbei
kommen weißt du weiß wo das ist ja ganz
alles ganz nah bei meinem haus gegenüber
einfach vom fluss okay dann muss ich
muss zwei leute wieder berlin
ja also ich bin auf jeden fall bei der
stadt ghom ist auch in der stadt um dort
leute okay das war's dann von der
heutigen folge bleibt uns wieder ja
immerhin war das wär's gewesen
ok na gut passiert aber egal wer blieb
wir verlieren diesmal nichts wir werden
nicht zurückkommen kürzerer folge heute
okay macht's gut
23 teams